رمضان له فرحه خاصه واجواء مليئه بالسعاده
فعدا عن ان الشوارع تتزين بالانوار
والفوانيس طقوس الموائد مختلفه ومتنوعه
بعدتها وتقاليدها لكن رمضان زمان كان له
طابع مختلف نتعرف عليه من خلال مجموعه صور
نادره من ارشيف المصور الصحفي سمير
الغزولي
هل كان في اطباق اساسيه على مائده الافطار
الملكيه يعني بنشوف بقى هنا المنيو اللي
كان بيتقدم
لحفل الافطار كان عباره عن حساء سخينه
السخينه دي عباره عن عيش شامي بيتقطع
بيتقلي في قلب زبده ويحطه عليه عسل اسود
وكان لازم فول مدمس بالبيض انطون بولي
اللي هو الصديق
الصديق الصدوق للملك فاروق فكان دائما ان
تنطولي لازم يروح يدوق الاكل اللي هيتقدم
للملك ممكن اقول اجراء امني كان بيتخذ
طبعا يعني فكان لو حصل له حاجه يعني كان
اول واحد يموت بول يعني فيروح بقى فدا
الملك ابويا مره بيحكي لنا حاجه بيقول لما
كنا بنصور الملك فؤاد على ترابيزه الافطار
بنشتغل بحاجه اسمها المغنيسيوم ما كانش
فيه حاجه اسمها فلاش يشتغل بالبطا كان
المغنيسيوم ده عباره عن بودره بتتحط على
صاجه وبترتبط بالكاميرا واول ما نيجي ناخد
اللقطه نروح الضربه انفجار عامل ضوء شديد
جدا الضوء ده بنصور الصوره الماده دي
بتطلع دخان اسود دخان ده ينزل على الاكل
ده سام خطر جدا فكان متبع دائما يجيبه اكل
من الخشب يتحطوا قدام الملك وبعد من
المصورين تخرج يشيلوا كل الخشب وينزلوا
بقى الاكل الطبيعي يعني الملك كان من اشد
الناس اللي كانت تعشق صوت القران
فكان معين 30 مقرئ يقراوا القران داخل
القصر الملكي طوال شهر رمضان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات